so what do you think the main factors to
consider what sort of conditions are you
trying to promote we can make the mix
basically dictates the conditions
because the four things that we need
that we all need for life on the planet
really you've got to have air obviously
we're gonna have water we've got to have
enough warmth and we've got to eat the
right food so but the food really is the
food for the microorganisms and the
microorganisms but in here if you think
you know within a teaspoonful of this
stuff there's up to a million different
microorganisms and they all need air and
water and they all need the warmth to
multiply it gets too cold if it's below
six degrees centigrade they just shut
off their game to sleep they go into
hibernation basically and that's one of
the big challenges with a small being
right this because it doesn't really
keep the warmth so you could construct a
a jacket on it some of the bins you can
even buy special compost duvet jackets
but there's some year in May should be
warm enough keep the temperatures up I
mean they will generate heat we can get
up to 60 even 70 degrees centigrade it's
very very hot so if those microorganisms
when they're all kind of you know
developing and they're going to go you
have any top tips for keeping the upon
post he thought he could use bubble wrap
layers of bubble wrap and tie that round
you could do something creative I'm sure
with sheets felt the sheep's wool make
something or you could use an old quilt
the inside well you could you could use
cardboard but I mean the more that you
put inside obviously you're taking up
more space again so really want
mutilation on the outside to get it back
in but yeah I mean a layer of cardboards
can help or you can make your own bins
up but of course people with spring
gardens they need to have a fairly
Ben but actually it's not the end of the
world if you're making the war it's not
the be-all and end-all for most of this
growing season it's gonna be okay
the worms are going to do a lot of the
work anyway in fact your compost heap is
going to turn into a worm er you've seen
the worms already invading this heap and
it's only in a couple of months and
there's quite a lot of structural
material in that which helps the air for
the worms as well so they'll like it I
mean a sick in six months to a year you
know you're gonna have really nice
compost so it'll just be slower it won't
get to 60 70 degrees it'll be above
ambient temperature it might be 30 40
degrees but it'll it'll stay it'll still
compost and compost happens where would
you best position your compost bin in
the garden well I've got these in in a
quite a nice open sunny position so
they're obviously gonna get get extra
heat from the Sun when the sun's out
that helps but I mean it's not it's not
really critical you can pretty much put
them anywhere really
I wouldn't put them too close to
buildings you know a bit further away at
the end of the garden anywhere but
pretty much anywhere is fine and you can
move them around the garden because
where they've been you're gonna create
very nice soil underneath you know and
they're easy enough to move these small
bins around which is one that's one big
plus side so that mismatch
okay there's enough air flowing through
your compost heap as well how would you
promote sort of aeration because
obviously we're trying to avoid the
bingo in anaerobic and you know trying
to create it's all down to them to the
food that you're putting in the mix of
materials so plenty of stuff like this
structural things that are going to take
a long while to break down anything
woody like that make sure there's plenty
of that you know throughout the heap so
you've got a kind of matrix that's
holding it apart that's letting the air
flow through that's all you need really
and you know like I say if you can't
find it you can't get it and you should
be able to get it I mean I'm just all
bits of stick I use a no dig system so
I'm not putting lots of carbon I'm not
digging it into my soil afterwards I
putting it on the top so that anything
like that any big bits of chunky woody
stuff is gradually incorporated into the
soil structure you know what you don't
horrible impacted that's what happens
with no structure a horrible smelly
skanky mess like that which you really
got to try and break up as much as
possible as you put it in you know and
then because it's just like pickled food
waste so that's why I'm doing it like
this breaking it up putting the
structure back into it and like I said
before the the cardboard will help to
absorb some of the moisture but it won't
give you the structure you've got to
have something chunky in there chunky
chip so a good indicator but you haven't
quite got the mix right if the say it
was too moist would be the aroma it
would be quite a bad odour oh yeah oh
yeah I mean that's what gives composting
a bad name isn't it people that people
love to just don't put enough air into
it and that's written that's really all
it is if there's not enough air things
don't break down
I mean look that's down the bottom
that's been there for a couple of months
it's probably it's still peelable you
get that absolutely amazing I don't know
what it was in the compost in the first
place to be honest but nothing has
happened to that preserved it's
preserved it preserved in alcohol